hey what's up welcome back to css3 at 30
days today we are going to be doing
something really fun and that is
creating a pacman animation we're gonna
make a little pac-man chasing the blinky
ghosts across the screen and it's gonna
be a lot of fun now what is pac-man if
you don't know what Backman is then
google it I don't know anyone who
doesn't know what pac-man is pac-man is
a classic arcade game it's timeless it's
a little yellow chomping ball that eats
little pebbles along this maze and
there's ghosts chasing him and when he
gets a special pebble he gets to chase
the ghosts and eat the ghosts and get
bonus points really fun simple little
game and we're just gonna create a nice
simple animation of pac-man moving along
a pack moving along their path chasing
the ghost so check this out in my
browser and I'm gonna show you what
we're making check it out right here
here it is now there are a number of
things going on all of this this entire
thing is CSS just CSS there's no
JavaScript nothing like that it's purely
CSS animations in css3
and that's what's exciting about it so
let's check out what's going on here we
have the path in the background with
these little pebbles it's very simple it
looks like he's eating them we also have
a circle here and that circle is
chomping and moving as well so a couple
things there then we have this ghost
blinky what blinky is doing is quite
literally blinking colors so he's moving
along the timeline as well along the
path and he's blinking colors in and out
from red to hot pink and he also has big
googly eyes and his pupils are moving
back and forth so he's got a number of
things going on I haven't seen a CSS
tutorial online yet other than this one
where they code the ghost as well I've
only seen CSS pac-man animations in
varying degrees in different examples
but I haven't seen one with the ghost so
I wanted to throw the ghost in here
because it's kind of exciting all right
so let's get coding let's make our
pac-man and let's make our goats and
let's animate them right now so jump
over here in your code editor download
17 pac-man you got the three files there
again give you a moment to download
those files and come right back here and
I'm not I'm gonna show you what's going
on here so we've got our index file with
some markup and I'm going to show you
what's going on in terms of the HTML
this is what the HTML looks like for the
pac-man we have a div at the class of
path wraps everything that is the
container which is simply that black
path right here with the dots inside
then we have div with the class of
pac-man that is pac-man that's it for
pac-man then we have a div at the class
of ghost which wraps a div with the
class of eyes and a div with the class
of skirt so the eyes are the eyes and
the pupils the skirt is the the bottom
of the ghost those triangles that look
like a skirt so and that's it for the
markup you don't have to code it because
it's already there and this isn't an
HTML course it's a CSS course but just
to show you how simple the HTML is and
all the magic happens in CSS jump into
your sandbox ok so let's get started
let's jump in and say we're gonna start
with path and that path is going to be a
position of relative
a width of 100% a height of 100 pixels a
background of triple three but whatever
color you want it to be works as well
padding 20 pixels all around box-sizing
I want to be border box because I want
it to be a fixed 100 pixel height if I
don't declare border box I'm gonna have
140 pixel height element because the
padding has to that height so I want to
be border box to keep that padding
within it so the element is 100 pixels
height max overflow:hidden very
important because when the Ghost when
blinky and pac-man go off the screen out
of the element I want them to disappear
not slide outside and be visible and be
kind of odd it would look like a little
glitch so that's it for the path save
that check it out here in the browser
it's just gonna be a big long like a
dark grey rectangle all right jump back
in here I'm just gonna tab in one and
say path virtual element after content
empty string position:relative no
position:absolute okay display:block
border top 12 pixels dotted white what
we're making here are those little
pebbles along the middle of the path now
if I say which 90% I have to give it a
width because of the condition that it's
in it's an after virtual element that
you cannot see until you give a width
and/or a height so we got the width and
the height is the 12 pixels of the top
border so simply I'm creating an element
that is just a top border the width is
90% if we save that and check it out
here in the browser we've got it right
here we've got our 12 pixel dotted
border we've got our 20 pixel padding on
the left and the top as you can see very
clearly the problem is is that this is
not centered within the path vertically
or horizontally so let's deal with that
right now over here in the code editor
simply going to say top 50% that's going
to push it down 50% of the height of
that parent element and left 5
percent because we are 90% width if we
want to fill a 100% width if we push it
over 5%
there's also 5% on the other side so now
we're perfectly centered in terms of the
top 50% we're gonna have a little
problem save that check it out it's
perfectly centered horizontally but
we've got too much space on the top
that's because it's going 50% down from
the top of this element so this actually
here to here is exactly 50% but I want
it to be 50% from the center of these
these dots because those dots are 12
pixels in height half of that if we
bring it up half of those pixels it's
gonna be perfectly centered so
margin-top negative 6 pixels save that
BAM now we are perfectly centered both
vertically and horizontally all right
now let's get down to the fun stuff let
it let's create pac-man
there's pac-man we're gonna say position
absolutes
zette index 99 so he's always on top of
everything top 50% we want him down 50%
from the top of the the path and now
that's it for now now you're not gonna
see pac-man because he is simply just a
position as that index and a top value
there's nothing showing us visually that
it's pac-man where that's gonna come
into play is the before and after
virtual elements so let's go down and
style those up we're gonna say pac-man
before and pac-man after in here we're
going to give them content of an empty
string display:block and we're gonna say
height:0 width:0 this is weird why are
we doing this well we're actually gonna
create pac-man out of a border not
actually out of creating a background
color okay so we're gonna say
position:absolute and then we're gonna
have a border solid 30 pixels yellow
that save that check out in the browser
it's gonna give us a yellow square and
that's because we have we have a 60 by
60 element because there's there's a
border top there's a border left is a
border bottom and there's a border right
of 30 pixels so now what we're gonna do
is we're going to remove certain sides
of the border in order to give us the
illusion or make it look like we have
half circles now what do I mean by half
circles I'm styling both before and
after with these identical styles so
there are two elements on top of each
other if I move one over say pac-man
after and I give him margin left of like
like 65 pixels save that check it out in
the browser I moved him over just enough
so you can see there's two and so now
now we're gonna leave it like that for
now and then style it up so you can see
what they both look like let's go back
here to before and after and let's say
margin top I wanted to be negative 30
pixels so he's centered in that path
border radius 100% should do the trick
or 50% 50% fine should give us a perfect
circle if I saved that and check it out
in the browser we got two perfect
circles sitting in the middle of the
path now let's remove some sides of the
border border right color transparent
save that check it out
so I removed the right border of the
four sides and now it actually looks
like pac-man we're not going to stop
there because we actually want two parts
to this pac-man a top part and a bottom
part and we're gonna make those chomp
together in this manner I don't really
know if I were just to have one chunk
out of one side of a circle I don't
really know how to connect those in an
animation but what we can do is create
two of these elements and animate them
individually so it looks like there's a
chomping animation this method
specifically I'm going to give credit to
travis nielsen of dev tips in his CSS
animations
tutorials on youtube check them out
he created a pacman loader and he did
basically pac-man he called him a
Chomper TomTom and he used the before
and after virtual elements and animated
those individually so I am going to give
credit where credit is due this specific
part is inspired by Travis so thank you
for that the rest of it however is a
mishmash of me just jamming and trying
to figure out how to make this work so
let's show you what's going on border
right color we're also gonna say border
bottom color is transparent now watch
what happens
save that check it out BAM now we got
two half circles cuz we cut out two
parts of the border but now what we're
gonna do is make the the after virtual
element have kind of an inverted version
of that so we can you'll see what I mean
so let's give the after pseudo element
the border color of yellow to reset it
back to a circle there it is now what
we're going to do is say border right
color is transparent and the border top
color is transparent as well if I save
that and check it out now we got the
other side now this will make a lot more
sense if I remove this margin left of
pac-man after and now they're connected
and they look like a pacman all we have
to do now is animate those two
separately to rotate a certain amount of
degrees on both sides so it looks like a
chopper let's do that right now so
simply go up to the pac-man before/after
and we're going to give it an animation
so animation we're gonna name it mouth
top and we're gonna do it over Oh point
seven seconds ease infinitely infinite
save that it's not gonna work until we
just find a keyframe so go to the bottom
and add your keyframes at the bottom of
your stylesheet that's usually a good
place to do it keyframes this one's
called mouth top and now it's just
simply playing with timelines so we're
gonna say at the 50% point of the
timeline so the
it goes from zero to 100% you can also
define it based on seconds I believe but
anyway we got 50% way through the
animation we are going to say transform
this is just CSS rotate I'm gonna say 44
degrees specifically chose that number
for a reason I'll show you why save that
refresh in your browser now it's all
rotating 44 degrees but I want the
bottom mouth to rotate negative 44
degrees so that one goes up rather than
down as well so simply all we have to do
is well while we're down here in the
keyframes let's define another keyframe
copy this one in fact save you some
typing paste it call it mouth bottom
rotate it negative 44 degrees scroll up
to your before and after copy this style
right here paste it in the after
pseudo-element style and change the name
to mouth bottom same exact animation
just inverted save it check it on the
browser BAM just like that chomping
perfectly now why did I choose 44 well
let me show you what happens when I do
46 degrees look at the back end the rear
end of pac-man there's a little bit of a
whoops a little bit of a line that
appears there and that's not okay
45 degrees shows the same hairline just
a little smaller 44 degrees was the
perfect number where I found no line at
all where the mouth closed to the most
okay now we all we have to do is move
him so let's create another keyframe
here and let's call it keyframes move
forward and I'm just gonna say at 0% of
the animation I want pac-man to be
negative 20% position I'll show you why
in a moment and at 100% I want him to be
at left 100% so that the left side of
pac-man is going to be 100% so he's
going to be off of the screen so if I
save this and move up to pac-man give
this an animation
of animation we called it move forward
five seconds linear and infinite save
that check it out in the browser watch
what happens see how he's coming out
from off of the screen on the left side
and then disappears on the right that's
exactly what we want let me show you in
that keyframe what happens if the left
is actually 0% what you might think he
starts his left side of the element
starts right here so he goes off screen
but then just appears out of nowhere and
it's not smooth but if we have it left
negative 20% where we know he's off the
screen that's gonna solved the problem
he slides out so he goes off the screen
like that comes back out gently I like
it
you might even sample 10% and see what
happens there if you wanted you could
play around with a number maybe that
looks a bit more like he's half off
there and half coming out that works too
so that's it for move forward now that's
it for pac-man actually so we made a
pac-man animation I could have left it
here but I thought nah I want to make it
ghost and I want to make that ghost run
so let's do that and now we're gonna
start stalling up this ghost okay so now
we're gonna say ghosts sure just called
them boo ghost position:absolute is that
index 99 so he's on top of the screen as
well top 50% left 20 percents I'm doing
that because I want him in front of
pac-man sure you showing a bit here
margin top we're gonna bring him up
negative 35 pixels because I want the
height to be 70 pixels in height and the
width to be 60 pixels in width so margin
top is half of 70 so that it's perfectly
aligned vertically in the center if I
save that and go back here you actually
won't see anything because we haven't
given them any colors so let's go back
to the ghost here again let's go back
round red let's get me
read save that now check out on your
browser so we've got a rectangular red
rectangle so now I just need to shape
him out so let's say the border top the
border top left radius is 70 pixels and
the border top right radius is 70 pixels
watch what happens just the top rounds
out the top left the top right that
looks nice and now let's start shaping
him out a little bit more he needs to
have that skirt and the eyes so let's
let's use this minimal amount of markup
as possible and let's say goes before
and now what we're going to do is so it
goes before and then ghost after and now
we're gonna use this use the ghost
before and after for the googly eyes the
the the white part of his eyes or her
eyes content and two-string
position:absolute background white
height 25 pixels and width 20 pixels I
want them to be not a perfect circle I
want them to be like long like you know
like a long eyeball
border-radius we're gonna make that 100%
perfectly round rounded edges all over
the place save it let's check it out see
what happened here so we have the right
shape I think that's a shape I want both
of them are right there they're stacked
on top of one another so we're gonna
have to move that so go back here in
your code editor and let's simply say
top 15 pixels from the top and then left
we're gonna go 4 pixels from the left
now really I'm just styling this is
where I want the before.i to be I want
the after eye to be over a bit so simply
go down here we're gonna declare a ghost
after pseudo elements virtual elements
you know what I mean
and we're just gonna say left 28 pixels
that's the only thing we need to change
save that check it out we've got our two
white eyes starting to come together it
looks pretty cool all right now let's
style those eyes so I have an element
called eyes in the markup but I want to
use the before and after virtual
elements as well so we're gonna go eyes
before and eyes after okay now again as
usual content empty string so it can be
visible on the screen position:absolute
so we can move it around wherever we
want it outside of the flow of the
document background blue we want blue
eyes Heights 10 pixels so these are the
pupils I probably could have called
these pupils but oh well wait 10 pixels
border-radius 100% that's border-radius
100% and save that let's see what's
happening okay so there's our little
blue eye up there we need to move it
down and over a bit so back here top 25
pixels and left 5 pixels save that there
it is looks good I don't think I need to
do anything else with that one now I
just need to move the second eye the
after virtual element over so I'm going
to say eyes
after and left is gonna be 30 pixels and
that will move him over to the right
spot I believe save that refresh its I
don't don't see it hmm I think this is a
Zed index problem go back here and both
of them gonna say that index 99 again
save that ban there it is it was just
hidden behind the eye you couldn't see
it so I needed to move that pupil
forward using Zed index that was
important okay now we have one more
thing to do here with the the look of
this little blinky is the skirt is what
I called it so let's go down another
style here whoops not there let's do it
after the eyes and let's go skirt
position let's go position:absolute
height:0 width:0 border:solid 10 pixels
triple 3 doing this because I'm using
borders for this and let's save that and
see what it is so there we go we have a
10 pixel border that is 3 3 3 the color
of the background so it looks it's going
to look like it's see-through
it's going to look like we're creating
those triangles so we have a square in
order to create a triangle out of the
border we need to remove the one of the
sides so that you can see through it to
see the red so watch this we're gonna go
border-top-color:transparent and save
that so ok now you can't really see
anything then we're gonna move it down
to the bottom I'm gonna say bottom
negative 10 pixels let's go bottom zero
to see where it is there it is but we
want him to be thought to be down more
so negative 10 pixels is the height of
that element
that should do the trick so there we go
so we got one there but now we need to
do a couple more so you can see how this
is working as pac-man passes through him
you can actually see where it's where it
is okay so now what we need to do is
simply style so be styled skirt with
that style but now we're going to style
the before and after virtual elements as
well
before and skirt after and now we're
gonna do is again content position that
absolute height:0 width:0 border is
gonna be solid ten pixels
triple three come to think of it I could
have just styled this in a much more
efficient manner why don't I go like
this
I'm gonna copy that and you remove all
these styles for now I'm gonna paste
this right there so all those have that
style and I'm gonna move these slightly
in a sec so save that check it out in
the browser okay so you can't see them
there because they're all stacked on top
of one another so now all we got to do
is style each of these individually so
I'm going to split these out okay so now
we're going to say before is going to
have a left position of
ten pixels going to move out over ten
pixels and then the after is gonna be
moved over left 30 pixels save it let's
check it out
okay you don't see it because these
actually have to have these are virtual
elements so they have to have a content
so simply all we're gonna do here is
content empty string copy that after
this is going to have content empty
string save that ban there it is just
like that so now we have the three
little skirt frills that make up this go
so now this ghost looks done so now all
we got to do is move the ghost google
his eyes and flash his color
we already created the move animation so
let's just move him so let's see what
happens if we go back up to the ghost
right here and wait here it is
and let's give him the animation of
animation move forward five seconds
linear infinite save that and let's see
what happens okay
he's moving but where's pac-man pac-man
is hiding directly behind him so that's
a problem we need to separate them so
what I'm gonna do is just simply delay
how long
pac-man takes until he starts his
animation you don't have to do anything
really extra you just go up to pac-man
and let me see here animation let's just
have another line here called animation
delay I'm gonna delay him 0.8 seconds
you can delete him however long you want
and it will space him out from the ghost
watch this okay
do you see what has happened now they're
spaced apart but when I refreshed look
where pac-man was he was just sitting
there and then he disappeared off the
screen negative 20% and then started his
animation that looks bad so all we have
to do is move pac-man by default 20%
left off the screen so he's just gonna
be left negative 20% save that now when
he's waiting for his animation he's
gonna be off the screen and then he's
gonna come out so now perfect so now if
i delay this longer like say two seconds
these are going to be spaced apart a lot
more
like that
and now looks like the coast is chasing
him I mean maybe that's fun maybe that's
a cool way of doing it maybe you want to
delay it like 2.5 seconds see what that
looks like
halfway is coming out and that looks
like the ghost is chasing him and now
like he's chasing the goat
whatever you want to do works totally
fine I'm gonna leave mine with something
like maybe one second for now okay now
the ghost needs to let's make him flash
let's make him blink
blinky alright let's scroll down to the
ghost we're going to create an animation
called color swap or blink maybe you
want to call it blink whatever works for
you so let's go back to the ghost and
let's give him an animation so we did
move forward but we're actually going to
do another one you can do a comma and
add another animation very easily just
like this so we're going to say you
could say color swap like this you can
call it blink
you know blink is kind of a fun one
blinky sure let's call it that
and we're gonna say 0.5 seconds is how
long it will take linear is the is the
arc and infinite we're gonna have it
happen forever so save that we need to
actually create that animation now
called blinky so ground create a
keyframe call it blinky and all we're
gonna do for blinky for the swapping the
color is halfway through the animation
timeline change the background to hot
pink halfway through it's gonna swap the
hot pink and then swap back to its other
color so save that check it out
so now he's blinking and you can change
that color to whatever you want you can
change it to I don't know like triple
three I don't know what's gonna happen
looks like he kind of like disappears
into the into the background which is
kind of cool I kind of like that and
maybe if I sped up the animation time I
don't know like 0.2 seconds let's see
what happens
you know that's something point four
seconds to see yeah I like that one that
looks fun but you can have whatever
color swap do you want and okay so
that's good now what we got to do is
going to make his eyes move back and
forth so we got to make those little
peepers and I move left and right so
what we're going to do is go to the
ghosts pupils which are eyes
okay and let's go with before-and-after
and we're going to say animation we're
going to start with peeper left to the
left peeper 0.7 seconds linear infinite
again okay and now the we have to create
an animation called peeper left
and so now if we just started with that
let's go down the bottom create a
keyframe called keyframes P / left and
then what we're gonna do with P / left
is at 0% , and 100% so the left position
that was gonna be 5 pixels and that's
because the position of the left eyeball
is actually 5 pixels so I want it to be
at it's 5 pixel default state and then
move over a little bit so let's move it
over P / left at the 50% mark of the
timeline I wanted to move over left
let's move it over a little bit so sorry
not that long I want it to be 10 pixels
over so if I save that we've already got
that set up refresh so now you see how
that eyeball is going back and forth but
now that you the right eyeball is not
there so that's because it's getting the
same animation as the left peeper so we
want to separate that and have it have
its own animation so while we're down
here let's copy this and do another
keyframe called P / right and the left
the 0 and 100% part of the time there's
going to be 30 pixels from the left
because that is the default state of the
right eyeball up here you can see I
after left 30 pixels so we want to start
there then move over probably 8 pixels
and then do that so I'll scroll back
down to P / right the left position
won't be 10% save this actually we're
gonna have to add that style so copy
paper left on this one and and the after
add P / right save that and watch what
happens right here so that's super weird
unless that's the style you're going for
but obviously it's not what we're going
for
so P / right the the 50% marked the left
position make it 38 pist
pixels so now they're going roughly the
seam you can see they're both there off
a little bit so maybe if I do this 35
pixel it's going to be the same distance
so they're both going to move exactly
the same way so now they're moving at
exactly a uniform speed and distance and
pace they're identical
but if you want to give them a little
bit more of a googly googly eye look you
can have it move a little bit few more
pixels so now they look a little bit you
know they're a little bit more googly
looking
yeah interesting up to you however you
want to do it you can even go something
like this like top I don't know I don't
know what's gonna happen here what's the
top the top by default for this is 25
pixels so maybe we move it to 220 pixels
let's see what happens
so that eyeball is like doing like a I'm
gonna take that out okay save that and
really refresh that's it
so we have our pac-man chomping moving
along the towpath going off screen
coming back out from the beginning we
have our blinky ghost all CSS flashing
moving and his eyeballs are moving back
and forth and that is really cool that's
really quite something that's it for
today this was a big lesson but I really
enjoyed making this so I really wanted
to give it the time of day so that you
can create something really interesting
show your friends or your mom and
they'll really think you're cool that
you spent a lot of time on your computer
making acne
[Music]